six weeks some women you know don't even
know they're pregnant within a month the
first month and I think the stats show
um
43 of pregnancies hap of abortions
happen within six weeks 36 percent
happen between seven and nine weeks 13
between 10 and 13 weeks so I think a lot
of people have sort of used like the
12-week number as sort of a
you know comfortable number that you can
wrap your head around but six weeks so
if
back to your point about DeSantis
if that's your message that you're going
to be more of a moderate and you know
kind of not play to the mega Wing but
also uh get some of the disaffected
Liberals and Independence on your side a
six week abortion bill you think that's
going to get women to vote for you yeah
no I know Homie don't play that